el distrito de muland Parker al norte de
copenhague tiene mala reputación la
legislación danesa la considera
oficialmente una sociedad paralela una
etiqueta que ofende a los habitantes del
barrio como said un joven estudiante de
arquitectura
cuando creces aquí Y ves como el
gobierno aplica estas leyes que solo van
dirigidas a una parte de la sociedad
bueno obviamente Hay un sentimiento de
injusticia
desde 2018 las autoridades danesas han
establecido criterios que definen estas
sociedades paralelas comúnmente
conocidas como guetos entre ellos se
encuentran la tasa de desempleo que aquí
es del 40 por ciento una tasa de
criminalidad superior a la media
nacional y sobre todo una tasa de
habitantes de origen no occidental que
supera el 50%. estos criterios permiten
su desmantelamiento aquí se han demolido
dos edificios y dos tercios de las
viviendas sociales se convertirán en
privadas sobre el terreno la autoridad
inmobiliaria se encarga de aplicar la
política gubernamental un método
agresivo pero justificado según el
dirigente vecinal en 2017 Tuvimos una
guerra de bandas de copenhague antes de
eso en 2015 hubo tiroteos terroristas de
alguna manera vinculados a Million todo
esto nos ha hecho retroceder años y
acabado con la paciencia de los
políticos
y hacían trasladado
250.000 familias la mayoría de ellas son
reubicadas en zonas más alejadas pero
muchos residentes como margen feller se
niegan a abandonar la ciudad me gusta
mucho esta zona porque la gente aquí es
muy amable
sientes que puedes hablar con todo el
mundo
en parking desde hace ocho años junto
con otro residentes locales presentó una
denuncia contra el por lo que consideran
como una política discriminatoria los
demandantes se apoyan en un informe de
las Naciones Unidas
es la primera vez en la historia de
Dinamarca que las Naciones Unidas se
unen a una denuncia contra el gobierno
por supuesto esta ley también discrimina
a las personas con salarios bajos o con
poca formación
pero el criterio esencial y determinante
es el de los orígenes no occidentales Y
eso es lo que denunciamos
en copenhague dos barrios se consideran
actualmente sociedades paralelas que
deben ser desmanteladas aquí en timbia
el municipio ha liberado terrenos para
viviendas privadas
una vivienda unifamiliar cuesta unos
300.000 euros un precio inasequible para
los habitantes del barrio
Leila creció en esta ciudad que ahora le
cuesta reconocer la joven estudiante es
danesa de origen tunecino y palestino
según ella con la ley antiheto se ha
grabado la estigmatización de la
población inmigrante
en primer lugar mi nombre no es danés mi
apellido no es danés y tengo esta
dirección
es muy complicado encontrar un trabajo
con todo esto el hecho es que la
política de integración con fórceps
dirigida por el gobierno social
demócrata cuenta con el apoyo de la
mayoría de los partidos políticos el
alcalde de copenhague encargado de la
integración a lava los resultados
la delincuencia está disminuyendo y
también podemos ver que en muchas
personas de estas zonas tienen ahora
trabajos normales
el desempleo ha bajado un 30% en el
sector Así que va en la dirección
correcta en Dinamarca la crisis
migratoria de 2015 en particular marcó
un punto de inflexión ese año el país
acogió a más de 75.000 personas frente a
una media anual de unas 50.000 desde
2010 un récord que ha reabierto el
debate sobre la inmigración y la
inmigración rayos holment es candidato
en la circunscripción de multan
representa un nuevo un vestido verde y
anti racista para él las leyes contra
los guetos pretenden sobre todo enviar
una señal a todos los inmigrantes
durante 20 años los sucesivos gobiernos
han ido reforzando las políticas de
inmigración
se trata de enviar un mensaje a los
refugiados inmigrantes para que no
vengan a Dinamarca
el tiempo todas las políticas se han
movido hacia la derecha y hoy tenemos
las leyes más estrictas del mundo
las autoridades quieren erradicar todas
las urbanizaciones consideradas guetos
para 2030 unos 20 distritos están
actualmente en la lista oficial de
sociedades paralelas